Suppose you just have filled a new problem report.
What happens next?
In a problem database like Bugzilla,
the problem goes through a number of stages.
Initially the problem report is unconfirmed.
If all the information in the problem report is valid,
then it goes into the new state.
A manager or the software change control board assigns the bug to an individual developer
who now works on it.
The developer now resolves the problem,
and for resolving the developer can choose between multiple resolutions.
be fixed, meaning that the problem has actually been addressed.
The problem can be marked as a duplicate,
meaning that the problem already exists somewhere else in the database
and therefore possibly somebody else is already working on it.
The problem can have a resolution of invalid,
meaning that the problem is not a problem
or does not contain the relevant facts.
A resolution of won't fix means that the problem will never be fixed,
which is a somewhat sad outcome for the one who originally submitted it.
Then we have works for me as a resolution,
meaning that the developer could not reproduce the problem.
Note that if the bug report is invalid or a duplicate
this may also be found out at an earlier stage of this,
and the problem immediately gets resolved, of sorts.
If the resolution is fixed, then the fix will typically be verified by the quality assurance team
and as soon as the final product finally ships with the fix in it,
then the bug report is marked as closed.
In case the problem reoccurs again,
it goes into a state of reopened and then needs to be reassigned to a developer.
This can also happen from the resolved state.
If additional information becomes available, for instance,
that makes the original resolution obsolete.